if not all of you are wondering how we
risk them just a tourist with our
weapons
oh God and hopefully one more great
empirical casting Imperial casting
well they just struck a b-boy pose
I think I've seen BTS do that kind of
pose all at once they look so cool that
Tableau was so cool but they also looked
like they were being tortured oh yeah
this is horrified let's be clear
this is awful welcome back to New
rockstars on Star Wars and or the pieces
of Rogue one are starting to come
together saw Guerrera is keeping his
partisan rank siled snoke actor Andy
Circus returns to Star Wars hopefully
won't get cut in half this time and
Cassian just met melshi one of his Rebel
Partners from Rogue one how will these
two escape this prison on narkina 5 well
you'll get your answers when you fix
this and dark
is Wookie leaks it's our weekly indoor
reaction show I'm Eric Voss I'm here
with Tommy back told Tommy what'd you
think of this episode I you know what I
I have I did my normal peruse the news
in the morning and some people were like
this episode was a little slow I love
the Intrigue I love the information I
like an episode that catches us up it
puts us all on here's where everybody's
at now just get ready for next week it
this was a uh uh a pot where the heat
had just been turned up and they stopped
the episode just before it boiled over
and you know what that just keeps me
coming back for more yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum let's get ready to put that
pasta in Al Dente that Andor that and or
penne vodka uh let's get going I yeah no
no complaints from me no complaints from
me at all there yeah not for me either
just because they they still smartly
build out the world in such a like a
yeah fascinating way this prison on
Arcana 5 like there's weird philosophy
that governs it with the number seven
governing everything uh but there's it
also just keeps everyone honest it's
like an odd number it's a prime number
right uh there's like enough distance
between the worst table and the best
table so you can climb up a ladder as
opposed to there just being like five of
them or they're just being like three of
them right or there'll be nine of them
nine wouldn't be prime but you know what
I mean or 11 of them like seven there's
like you know seven is just kind of this
prime number throughout nature I I
wouldn't go down a rabbit hole with the
number seven so that it was just like
missing parts of the episode I was like
oh wait yeah Andy Circus is talking oh
God numerology has reached Wikileaks and
as if and has affected it I'm gonna pull
tarot cards after this it's gonna be
great we're gonna have a great time hey
I mean numerology has been coursing
through the veins of new rock stars for
years at this point it just finally
caught up to Andrew that's true we were
originally going to be a Psychic Friends
Network right that was our original
business model we sold we sold all our
ad space on telling fortunes but
unfortunately Miss Cleo went to prison I
did do a Miss Cleo impression for an ad
spot one time years ago I'll never do it
again because I don't think that was
cool but yes Eric we were just talking
about cancelable things we did like 10
years ago for Pay By by major companies
that were like oh yeah if that ever
resurfaces uh uh I'll probably you know
at least have to take a few weeks off of
work but anyway uh why don't we talk
about what happened in this episode of
Andor yeah take us through it Tommy okay
episode 8 of Andor starts off with
Cassie and Andor in a bit of trouble
he's getting shipped off manhandled by
Shore Troopers it's continues I'm so
glad he got one more I'm just a tourist
I love that but to me like they didn't
hear that I think there's something in
the in his training to blend in by
repetition of phrases because he says it
so much and he's a smart person so the
fact that he keeps mentioning he's a
tourist I think he's hoping those words
will be like in any like if things are
being recorded they'll be like all this
guy said is I'm just a tourist over and
over again I don't know maybe I'm
thinking too much but the fact that
there's you know people who worked on
the Bourne movies it's like all those
little phrases repeated over it usually
come back to me something yeah and he's
so good at maintaining his Alias name
too you know like he never wavers nakina
five is the prison planet they go to the
planet is home to an imperial Factory
facility and given that he's fit enough
to work he along with a bunch of new
prisoners are tasked with back-breaking
manual labor I think making like Mustang
engines for the Imperial storm ships it
looks like the whatever they were making
those ratchet sound effects were
incredible I love it was it was like
ASMR for prison Labor uh you know
there's a lot of wardens in this country
who probably just like fall asleep to
the sounds of uh license plates being
handled they're Googling vibrating
floors that almost kill people tomorrow
morning they're like how can we make all
the floors so Cassian meets a bunch of
people his old friend as we spoke about
he also meets his supervisor Kino played
by Andy Circus is I mean are we gonna
get some keto DNA in there to make snow
because that we're probably maybe
talking about that later I don't know
maybe we're not maybe this is a rope
here not only is the work hard but they
also have a Sprint segment which sees
them forced to work harder and faster
with the least productive table being
once again shocked by the floor
disciplined meanwhile my voice zero
continues to work his desk job but he's
taken away when he finally he comes face
to face with Lieutenant Miro permanent
scowl that actress is incredible by the
way to do that like
oh yeah her like
bass fish frown the entire time she
looks awesome uh she's noted that he's
been looking at all these different
queries that he put in about Cassie
nandoah six different complaints seven
but she wasn't counting that morning
Cyril admits he's been using limited
resources he has at his disposal to
figure out where Andor is and then I'll
buy up by default clear his own name all
is not well on ferrics folks Marva is
pushing herself way too hard trying to
Aid the Rebellion both Bix and Brasso
are returning Brasso come to check on
her before Bix decides to go to her
friend Pock and use his com Tower to
contact Lutheran the call is intercepted
by Clea who is a perhaps more ruthless
than Luther we know I mean like she's
Luther assistant but I think she's the
more ruthless one or at least the more
uh unable to hide her ruthlessness
there's no bleeding heart there with you
no not at all between his shop and the
tower Bix and POC are both subsequently
arrested by the Empire and we leave them
both in apparently big trouble Pock
having been tortured and Bix seemingly
on the verge of torture elsewhere we get
a little diner scene with Vel and Sinta
and Sinta painfully informs Val she's
gonna stay put she's not going the
struggle will always come first meaning
the relationship that they have with
each other is second she kind of takes a
shot at Vel having escaped a life from a
wealthy family but we don't know what
family yeah right they don't mention
what family I don't think Eric but I
mean I think at this point it's got to
be Lutheran right like I don't know
though because he's in the Rebellion so
couldn't it I'm wondering if it's
another major Star Wars aristocratic
family name that we you know we might
recognize if it's like oh she's the the
senator from uh Naboo Palpatine
can't wait a second
please God no thanks your stepfather
Binks uh all right but it's Thackery
Banks from the Hocus Pocus movies anyway
uh Focus up Tom you got one job here
Miro takes this to the Imperial group
takes the information uh she got from
Cherokee it suggests that Andor could be
part of the Rebel group she's convinced
that this is the best lead they have and
she begins to work with Cyril to learn
more now we're seeing where Cyril's path
is headed he points out that Andor had
organized a group of accomplices with
him including Luther okay Cyril does his
best but before Mira leaves he points
out that he was a great supervisor he
did his job diligently he wants his own
roll back and that's what always happens
to the petulant over ambitious bad guys
right they push it one step too far Miro
goes listen you simp
I ain't promoting yeah you ain't getting
your old job back and she wants him do
not raise the alarm again bummer for
sure I'll have a feeling that's not the
last we see of him meanwhile mon mothma
mommy mothma continues to whine and dine
as she learns from Tay and others that
the new p-o-r-d legislation has been
passed which of course means everyone's
sentences have been doubled thanks to
the rebel activity that to me seems a
little oppressive uh slightly terrifying
that you can just increase prison
sentences from within probably no
examples of that in the real world the
tightening of security across the Galaxy
leads Lutheran to make a big decision in
mystically uh he's not sleeping but he's
been hiding for too long as a result he
decides to head off for segra Milo
interestingly he meets Sagar era
Forest Whitaker's character from Rogue
one of course oppression breeds
Rebellion he reminds saw leaving things
on quite an ominous note after they fail
to strike a deal yeah a lot of
interesting things happen this episode
Tommy I mean the idea that the ISB has
been hunting Lutheran and gave them the
code name of axis yes which is that was
so specific I mean obviously the axis
has like a a different meaning when it
comes to his connection point to all
these different wheels of the uh of the
Rebel uh functions but he accesses also
the name given to these Central Powers
in World War II the Axis powers of
Germany and Italy and Japan and the fact
that like the Nazis are calling us Nazis
are you kidding me I know come on
gaslighting I think I don't know or just
plain old misinformation misinformation
right yeah I mean they don't know the
history of our world I was just like a
fun I mean all the all the freaking Nazi
parallels the way that they sorted
Cassian into like uh able-bodied worker
and other people to like now it makes me
worried about people going to that other
prison like oh so you can't work so what
does that mean for you and then that
moment where they all go into the shower
right like how can you not see the fact
that they have to take off their shoes
like ever been a holocaust museum in DC
absolutely go to it you'd see the
horrifying tragic pile of shoes as you
walk in yeah stuff with nightmares and
it happened Jesus Christ anyway but yeah
no right a very subtle Tony Gilroy is
not taking it easy on us with Andor he's
like you know what this is Star Wars but
you're also gonna have to see some real
life parallels and uh and uh it's not
going to be we are not seeing a Cantina
Band as of yet so the uh the levity of
the levity of some of the moments of
Star Wars have yet to come although who
knows perhaps and or season one or the
first half of Android we got a dog on
set dog on Set uh just kidding uh there
is no I'm not kidding I'm not I'm just
my anger is not real the maybe perhaps
the end of the first 12 episodes of
Andor and with him on the moon's event
or dancing with the Ewoks I don't maybe
they'll do that maybe after all of this
pain and and you know uh uh tyrannical
rule imagery uh Cassian will end up
dancing with little uh life-size teddy
bears perhaps but he's not allowed to go
outside to join the party he has to stay
in the tree house so that way you'd have
and or indoor on Andor no and or indoor
on indoor damn it I almost had it you
got it you know what let's put it on a
T-shirt and sell it through our own
store Eric and Tommy's T-shirt shop
arama.com oh did I miss miss an
opportunity and or taking a Hond or to
indoor indoor because with the hondura
craft right can I give you some candles
and or taking the Hond or to be indoors
at on Endor sounds like a vision of
Splendor that I shall not forget or uh
anyway uh I want to stick my face in a
blend door oh no don't do it
all right Eric I got a question for you
how
much will Cassie and escape the prison
yeah that I mean I even if they're able
to get to some fresh air are they gonna
swim to the shore I don't know they have
those weird whirlpools
down there oh God
there's there's water Snorlax beautiful
water silage
and boba's still down there too
the uh it seems like the only way you
can get to these is if you have a
shuttle land on it like even the prison
guards that work on it they don't have
like Tie fighters hanging around that
they can just get off of it you know so
it's like a perfectly designed prison
maybe the best it makes me wonder why
aren't all the prisons in Star Wars this
small design right because by comparison
the ones that we've seen on uh the
Mandalorian you know that floating one
in Space the space station the wool
Bonnie in Rogue one they seem like real
poopy prisons maybe just like the Empire
uh had a private contractor designed
this one and he's a freaking Maniac
jumps the Star Wars Universe no one will
escape this one my perfect the other
ones are like yeah just throw people in
the hole hey I got my best New Jersey
contract is on this we're gonna bring
out a bunch of concrete and we're just
gonna make it a great prison and you
just put people in there and you're
Bland Bon Jovi Adam all day long
hey you call that a prison I call that
heaven
just non-stop Prince of New Jersey are
you kidding me
be Living on a Prayer narkita five let's
talk about it though it is one of the
most fascinating settings overall that
we've seen in Star Wars it's this prison
design with cruel Perfection and this
obsession with the number seven seven
floors seven rooms seven tables seven
men per table seven seconds to get to
your room I'm pretty sure there were
seven aquatic prison bases because you
only see it from like outside the window
of the shuttle but I think there were
seven of them uh and we talked about
this number seven how it's you know it's
a prime number and there's just like
it's enough for a crowd but not too much
for or it's enough for a party not too
much of a crowd you know
um it's kind of the perfect number there
uh electrified floors prisoners forced
to uh walk around on Barefoot guards who
wear these insulated Moon boots uh I
loved how this is all presented as a
game yes it reminded me a lot of squid
games and then we also learned that they
have these squigs that they drink on
Coruscant like a chandelier yeah um
Delight so I'm calling this episode
Squig game yeah because I think that's
what it is they get electrified and then
yeah we talk about these food hoses
which just feels like an infantilizing
thing it's an umbilical cord right like
you're just getting nourishment so that
you can just stay alive right
um we've prisoners who are killing
themselves like what a death too like
there's stepping on the floor outside of
yourself the cells have no doors it's so
sadistic right like it's like you may
notice we don't carry guns here at the
prison we have no means of like keeping
you here no need to it's because it's so
brutal you just take one wrong step and
you're dead this felt very dystopian to
me because it was so clean and so
perfect very yeah yeah so efficient
um and they have this way of like
self-reinforcing it like the the
prisoners kind of motivate and uh and
punish each other in a way like they're
all in competition with each other it's
it's again it's nimics Manifesto yes uh
in incarnate like keep them arguing and
squabbling with each other and they
don't come after you and that's exactly
what has happened but there are little
hints there's little signs that they're
starting to work together so I'm on
casting stable it's Mel sheet it's
played by actor Duncan Powell he played
runescot melshi in Rogue one he's a
rebel commander in casting's unit who
helps Cassie and break Jin are so out of
that prison on wobani and he leads the
rebel faction in the bunker on Scarab
it's a real really the first link in the
chain of a relationship that we actually
saw in Rogue one we've seen characters
but they haven't really met yet you know
saw Guerrera almost only been talking
with Lutheran makma hasn't talked to
anyone else they're all going to meet
each other by the end of this series uh
but I like how we see it gives us hope
you know because they did have this
moment where Mel she aggressively tells
Cassie to just give up all hope that
their sentencing numbers can change at
any moment uh and that he shouldn't even
look at the number we have a long way to
go but they're both gonna make it out
which is nice to know uh in this prison
we saw Tiger using hand signals to
communicate with inmates across the way
so there is some kind of like system
that they've devised it makes me wonder
like how how did they develop that
system either they must have been
friends who already had these kind of
baseball signals uh or like they just
did it organically you know like they
have a letter system or just like some
kind of thing yes this means yes this
means no and then the person across or
they have no idea
and he's like no no I was working in the
prison late one night my eyes do you
know Halloween's coming soon everyone
anyway
the uh you know this is probably just
like a Star Wars equivalent of ASL yeah
right let's yeah I'm overthinking it I
think now on the first day when Cassian
arrived you could tell he was definitely
clocking all the inefficiencies like he
was definitely taking notes in his head
because they all had to like repeat
orders to him they're like what did I
just tell you keep moving he's like hold
on I'm taking mental photographs of all
this
um he notices how inefficient they are
how much they run behind schedule when
some when they have to move someone from
one sector to another that throws them
off and how much that freaks them out
like they're being punished by this as
well and how stressed out that makes
them how they don't really get along
like really it's the design of this
prison that uh has made it so uh
functional it's not like the the
Staffing that is made as functional as
it is
so if if Cassian can find a way to
bypass that design or just like uh tip
over the first Domino these these prison
guards as you said they are not armed
but like they can if they just can just
get enough prisoners with a couple of
those Moon boots they're gonna be good
and he's he clacked exactly how they
just store extra ones right there he's
like the kid at the roller rink who just
looks at the wall of shoes and says
these can all be mine
I could take these air monarchs I could
take these new balances I could steal
these British Knights what was it BK did
you were you that old did you have BK
British Knights that were like a Reebok
oh I never had oh my God I don't know
forget it does Reebok even still exist
um we should check their apartment all
right um
that kind of I got a 9 30 a.m snort out
of me last night
all right anyway so what will the first
Domino be in the prison I honestly think
it's gonna happen without Cassie
um I think we're already seeing it table
five our old man who love the poor guy's
falling behind I think he's gonna either
drop or he's gonna cause him to fall
behind it's gonna cause some infighting
among the people at that table or other
people in that room and then Tyga has
already got his own thing going on he's
gonna use that the hubbub over like Oola
dropping dead or them transferring oolap
out of there to coordinate with this
other guy cassian's gonna see this and
be like here's my chance and he's gonna
say all right I know they keep it here
they're falling behind schedule and
anytime this happens let's do this there
are a couple of them are going to get
their hands on some rubber boots they're
going to be able to turn off that
electrical grid for the entire complex
and it's going to allow all these
prisoners on all levels to write a lot
of the prisoners will die though I think
they're gonna it's gonna be a bummer I
think a lot of them aren't gonna make it
out but Cassie and Mel she will at least
Escape I think think whenever like
prisoners die that's when they have to
transfer new prisoners there so they're
going to use that exchange when uh it's
a real quick handoff I think they know
that uh there'll probably be some um
dressing up as prison guards yeah
involved with this right I think
Cassie's gonna have to do that so when
like they come out to greet the other
one they're gonna get uh on that ship uh
to uh jump in the back hijack it get out
of there say F off to the rest leave
some real stinky farts on their way out
I'm just a tourist I'm just a toast he's
gonna say that to everyone yeah I'm just
a tourist you don't have to stay it's
okay you're fine you're safe now no I'm
just a tourist uh he doesn't know he's
he assumes all of his life is just a a
prison he's kind of like Truman and
Truman Show yes he doesn't know where
none of this is real nothing's wrong who
are you talking to my question for you
Tommy is what do you think they're
building this facility also what do you
think they're eating oh are we looking
at some Soylent Green I think they're
eating uh I hope they're not a sponsor
uh Soylent that Soylent that Soylent
like the those drinks remember Soylent
drink that was like this is the perfect
food we are we are marketing food to
people that uh have no interpersonal
relationships no offense if you're
Soylent drinkers call in if you are and
I'll give you a hug but it's like just
drink Soylent you don't need to eat food
you don't need to talk to people while
you're eating anymore that's what I
think they're eating what do I think
they're building I think they're
building engine parts to me all of the
ratchets it felt like a NASCAR pit crew
felt like they were doing a lot of
riveting a lot of uh socket wrenching
giant socket wrenches like I said the
sounds were very satisfying I think
they're parts of giant engines that
either you know keep uh keep those
whirling Waters around or perhaps power
Starships I don't know but I believe
those were uh uh parts to keep things
moving uh is what is what I'll say they
looked very solid they needed to be
sealed very tightly I uh I so my belief
is engine parts I know that's a little
vague but I'm not a car guy I mean they
all these uh Parts had like this uh
almost like a spider grid kind of look
to it right a lot of like parts are just
like extended out and they were round I
think these plug into Tie fighters like
I think they're part of a TIE fighter
cockpit like it's either something that
keeps the uh the the seat in place it's
the hood of the cockpit that gets
lowered down uh once you go in like
something very specific that like once
Cassian puts it together I think he'll
just kind of throw up in his mouth a
little bit like we know it's some some
future Mission he's probably gonna
hijack a TIE fighter and he's going to
look at it and recognize the piece that
he's holding in his hand and it'll be
like I made this or would it be even
better is if he realizes that and they
start sabotaging them and you cut to a
montage of people dropping out in their
Tie fighters in the bottoms just
dropping out in them flying out into
space
I guess that'd be more like as soon as
they go to space the hatch opens up and
they shoot out
yeah
yeah oh my God yes that's what I want
let us know down below what you think
these prisoners are working on we have a
couple more questions we want to get to
this episode we want to thank Uncommon
Goods for sponsoring this episode your
loved ones are complex beautiful
Mysteries but Uncommon Goods knows
exactly what they want whether you're
shopping for Mom Dad teenagers in-laws
or your best friends Uncommon Goods
makes it easy to find remarkable and
truly original gifts for anyone on
Common Goods once your holiday season to
be stress free so check out their
selection of thousands of items today
yeah we found a couple of great gifts on
their site like tell me what'd you find
I you know my family have been uh we've
been decorating our house for both
Halloween and all fall with the fall
experiences collection we love it we
love the fall Goods I don't mind a
spooky skeleton but nothing makes me
happier than a gourd with some leaves
around it a pumpkin patch if you will
pre-slaughter uh Tommy you're painting
uh Robert Frost poem in my head and I
want to walk both sides of that road yes
what am I saying yes it's just Uncommon
Goods makes me feel poetic because of
how great their products are yes it
brings out the poet in you on Common
Goods looks or products that are high
quality unique and often handmade or
made in the US they have the most
meaningful out of the ordinary gifts
anywhere who knows what holiday shipping
will look like this season in the unique
gifts at Uncommon Goods can sell out
fast so shop now and get it taken care
of early uncommon experiences are more
than just virtual classes there are
unexpected opportunities to have fun and
connect in new ways from tarot card
reading romantic map making cooking and
Mixology classes and more Eric I want to
pause you real quick can you and I get
in a romantic map making class as soon
as humanly possible sorry Kelly yeah no
you gotta you're benched for this map
making session no matter what they're
into Uncommon Goods is the perfect gift
from art and jewelry to Kitchen home and
bar Uncommon Goods has something for
everyone not the same lackluster gifts
you could find just anywhere when you
shop at Uncommon Goods you're supporting
artists and small independent businesses
to get 15 off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.commongoods.com WikiLeaks
for 15 and off don't miss out on this
limited time offer Uncommon Goods we're
all out of the ordinary yes and we also
want to thank wondery go deeper into the
canals of new Menorah or the minds of
kazadum and more with the official Lord
of the Rings rings of power podcast if
you're like me you can't just watch the
episodes and turn to your roommate Jimmy
and go what the heck just happened no
you need some help and that's where host
Felicia Day and several special guests
provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunners JD Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale and I
mean incredible baby if you're a Tolkien
toker like me you gotta listen to this
Felicia also goes behind the scenes with
the cast and crew then we get jaw
dropping stories and Easter eggs hey
Felicia back off that's our world you
don't want to miss watch the rings of
power on Prime and listen to all eight
episodes of the official Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast for
free on Amazon music download now
download the Amazon music app now baby
get into the power okay so a question I
have yeah uh the fact that Cyril and
Deja have met it kind of feels like the
world of Star Wars is so big it's really
hard for characters like this to meet
again by happenstance yeah unless one of
them does something bold yeah so uh how
do you think Cyril will meet deadger
again my thing is that cereal's gonna do
something real stupid he's gonna keep
pushing it and detra's gonna be like
didn't we already have it yeah do you
think she'll come around and recruit him
or is he just gonna be on his own path
and she's gonna hate him well in a way
the reason she would be hating him is
because they are so similar right she
only is where she is now because she
broke the rules and raised attention and
then used that attention to embarrass
the immediate Superior into to having
her higher up Superior my man from Game
of Thrones whose Name Escapes me right
now be like yes I agree with you instead
of this other blood or not blevant
forgive me part again part again yes
party games party games party cons okay
you're out it's it's Deidra time so now
here's what I think
Ciro we've had so much footage of Cyril
being cowardly right him stammering we
see his leg literally shaking in this
episode every he's like mumbling under
his breath to his mother like I'll tell
you when to eat your breakfast you're
gonna have to go you're not getting a
Christmas gift for Life Day this year
you're getting cold uh but anyway I
think Cyril will like you said he's
gonna act out and do something so stupid
the dedras he's gonna get dedra's
deidre's attention and
it's going to force her to interact with
him again and he's gonna have a trump
card he's going to do it on purpose he's
gonna do really stupid to raise
attention again and then he's going to
have a panic Last Resort this is what I
have and she's gonna go this guy is the
key to Bringing Down Andor which has
become my new obsession his obsession
has become my obsession I will say the
sexual tension between them could not be
cut by anything because it is not thick
at all it does not exist which I think
is refreshing you have like er you have
like uh over overbearing young employees
both very similar and neither of it's
not like oh this is like the Empire's
Han and Leia it's like nope these two
people would hate each other in real
life and would never be together right
so good job Tony Gilroy I'm not falling
into uh tropes of the 80s and 70s uh
anyhow so yeah I think that's how
they'll meet again I think um something
in this Imperial facility also makes
Fuel and that somehow there will be a
fuel related report that shows up on uh
on
gief kurgos yeah escape and then his mug
shot's gonna show up on uh it's a it's a
moving and cereal is going to see it and
be like mother I just found this guy it
just says Keith gergo occupation to I'm
just a tourist underneath
wait a second he's like a Pokemon whose
name is I'm just a tourist I'm just a
tourist hey why could why can't Pokemon
talk but Digimon can you know what I
think it's because it's a digital world
if if they're from the Digimon region of
France then their Digimon that can talk
if not they're just sparkling Pokemon I
make that joke for every single property
It Never Lands I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
watch some episodes of uh Pokemon don't
leave me until we talk about what's
going on with monmouth's daughter lady
yeah why was she being nice I no I think
Leda is on to on to her yeah I think
later agreed noticing take home like
you're over here a lot and I think she's
going to blow this wide open and that
man's gonna have to distance herself
from her dog yeah you pretty you
predicted that last week and I was
stunned I was like no they're family and
then I was like oh family betrays each
other all the time Eric's right uh
I'm just I'm just I'm just a dummy Eric
yeah she's I mean whenever a teenage
girl or boy is nice to their parent it's
because they're planning something far
more nefarious anytime I was ever nice
to my parents from the age of 13 to I'll
say 31. it was because I had something
duplicitous just below the surface the
later I'm on to you girl mommy I will be
excuse me my room I did steal some beer
and I'm gonna drink it in my room did I
say the wrong part I'm gonna have some
squigs I'm gonna put some squigs in my
Coruscant pale ale oh yeah I bet there
is of course on pale ale somewhere out
there there's got to be a micro Brewer
with like a man bun who like comes out
and he's like you guys are drinking all
the like mainstream lagers and Al's but
if you come down to try my pale ale
it'll really blow your mind
we'll leave it there for this episode of
WikiLeaks you can follow me at eavos you
can follow Tommy at Tommy bech told
follow a new Rockstar subscribe to
WikiLeaks wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching we'll see you
next week for our reaction episode 9 of
Andor where they probably break out of
this prison we can't wait thank you for
watching we have spoken
thank you